good morning gamers it's me yeah we're
back with more minecraft because that's
what everyone wants that's what I want
this is the life were living where my
boys at when my boy side IKEA bird yeah
oh oh I just realize this game would be
perfect for from for Logan Paul he could
have his little maverick Logan don't go
near this game
come here spend come here I made some
changes you can tell it's a little
cleaner now beautiful beautiful just
like spruced it up a bit
I built this this is very important okay
I built this church and I didn't build
it just for anyone it's beautiful it
took a long time
isn't that right Sven I build it for
water sheep this is the Church of water
sheep follow me Smee this is where
sheeps can live and be happy under the
stars and they're safe at night and they
can also go out in the yard if they feel
like it if they feel like it's been let
them swim they are free they are free to
do as they please because what their
sheep set them free that's right
what the Sheep did this beautiful it was
mine says idea to make things right for
what happened to water sheep it's the
latest thing I could do right I know he
would be proud so today we're gonna
kidnap some people so I got to go back
to sleep it's not right at Kinberg be
quiet IKEA Birds gosh I'm trying to
sleep UDP oh god there's something spawn
in my basement hello hello I'm gonna
cure you
alright we're fine it's bad races friend
we gotta go kidnap people today follow
me
so what do I need to kidnap people
fishing rod I think I might need a
piston Oh God
can he fly into the lava no cost with an
opener right
I guess I never showed you around close
okay cool glad you enjoyed the tour
where my Pistons at oh okay there's one
thing I forgot I want to do before we
say hi to people delivering their look
look I have so many diamonds like where
is it where's my super pickaxe marry
this one fortune 3 is insane
I get like 20 diamonds from one spawn so
you know maybe it's time for me finally
finally make my diamond armor okay I
know I look very cool with my little
things right Claus yes but it's it's
time and time I think it's its diamond
time god I don't like spending I like
saving I'm a saver in case it was an
obvious all right armor chess plays Bing
or diamond boots bong diamond helmet
ching-a-ling a ping a small and of
course I don't really need these but I
guess I'll go with it for the aesthetic
cover me and diamonds baby boom boom
boom boom I will give you a diamond
armor if I could please sit
I didn't cost me that much look it's
still it's still filled as long as the
diamond armory is filled I am being
grilled in diamonds okay cool I guess
I'm just that rich huh gosh I'm running
a little thick on space here yeah okay
so now we gotta enchant it it's not a
coincidence that I'm level thirty right
now okay I was planning this what do I
wanna what is more important I assume
the chess place is more important fire
protective unbreaking what's better fire
protect its pretty good right I don't
know I don't know what do I get from the
other ones protection three that sounds
good all right there that is strider
what is that Google Depp's tried it
right now I'm deaf try there the charm
is speeds up how fast you can move under
water what water boots look
cool all right now I got the link how
much did that cost me oh I can only
chant one and then I leveled down
okay gamers I'm gonna level up I want
good enchantment on my epic armor
strider that's awesome
okay fine we'll go you guys can't come
no no no applause it's too dangerous for
you in here do not follow me do not
follow me class do not follow me it's
too dangerous
I improved the hub a little bit so this
is north south east and west just so I
know their locations but there should be
another blocks three levels I can do
that fast I can do that faster than you
say oh god you said it already oh god
what do I do now this is so embarrassing
where the Frick my quartz aunt for those
of you who are noobs at Minecraft not me
just mind the quartz baby you level up
faster than you can say you love a lot
fast thanks beautified for the epic tip
how the Frick do you guys get in here oh
my god just just go go you're don't
belong here no pixel out go back home to
pig Lane now I'm not trying to do
anything I'm not trying to do anything
bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro we're bros right rose yeah you came
to my home you came to my home alright
you know what you know what you know
what you know what you know you know you
know oh my god you like houses so much
here I'll make you one have fun all
right we're back let's go back home to
uragan and smug and insane
cool i was supposed to kidnap people
that was the point of this episode come
on
alright Sven sorry I got a little
sidetracked look I'm level 33 class yes
yes yes yes yes this is gonna be epic
I know I know legs or or helmet I'll do
chest place oh it requires more laughs
please oh my gosh why did no one tell me
about the lot please okay fire
protection nah fam I ain't down with
that how do I get different enchantments
I don't have time for T P P P our legs
what do we get what if we get come on
unbreaking fine protection for Oh
you get bonus boners and chant man damn
depiction bored
Wow okay so I'm still over 30 so I can
still do this fire protection what else
did they get nothing useless pathetic
alright I guess we'll go with level two
the last name clause I know I know but
we look the same right we look similar
we're not so different you and I all
right oh yeah it's kidnapping time class
get on my yeah that's right get on my
shoulder then you can come too
it's a party it's gonna make sure I
bring some food that is definitely not
what I did
I'm just worried Klaus is gonna fly into
the lava like that Barbie does in that
viral video oh god I needed a piston
break
how do you make them again redstone now
ah
I built this contraption to make it
easier okay alright gamers let's roll
out oh look my sheep escaped surprise
Pikachu face come on Sven so I know
there's a city nearby it's not too far
away I just realized I don't need your
gun freaky old alarm gamers this would
be a lot easier if people were still in
this city all right we got to go boat
Sven get in how fast this cost not very
you can do it Klaus just fly why can't
you just get on my shoulder so something
I can click to get him on my shoulder
you're not a dog Klaus I've been tired
of telling him oh my gosh here we go
there's villages in the waters excellent
this is just what we want
let's find water level cool cool we lost
across you know I take back what I said
about this playthrough being over when
swen dies this place through is over
when I die when I'm fully stacked in
diamond okay it will officially be I'll
be done officially gonna try to find the
fortress today as well I know that's a
little difficult but I want to try it oh
you want to try it please okay here we
are at friendly City now who should we
kidnap who should come with us
someone good right how about you
useless they want someone that we can
trade with alright leather guy nah
Gucci maker another Gucci maker I guess
like Gucci maker it is good because what
you can do is you can grab them and put
them in boats and then he can row the
boat on land just like you know what
you're coming with me
alright do you have any choice in the
matter hey you want to leave you can
leave anytime you want baby you're the
Titanic music no don't do that and we're
off
say goodbye to your friends you will
never see them again ever again from now
on I've got Sun is setting we got to
hurry up here how do I get the thing up
from the water that is the question
right and if I trying to support this
guy so now we're stuck right but I think
there's a simple Jedi mind trick ah
Frick that's not gonna work Pierre needs
to be here can you use this wiring
underwater
there's redstone torch work it will work
I'll look for enough time okay you just
tell the cords now what the hell where
ships coming to save you buddy don't
worry
close the door use the sponge it's
already dried out okay great now wait
I'm underwater how do I use the sponge
well all the water disappear well that's
easier
Luntz them up oh god this creeper not
near church not near me at ball another
one big B word row row row your boat hey
gamers we got a new addition to the fam
there's people don't you my kidnapper
only I can shoot up
[Music]
I hate you all I hate you all okay
perfect
and kidnap successful you're our new DJ
that's right hey Blaine hex he doesn't
even want to look at me listen this is
your job now I don't care play that
funky music come on let's hear it
this is obsessed with their what's
happening over there okay gamers I don't
really know I need guidance I need
guidance what to continue I need water
sheep to tell me what to do but the
Sheep we have brought you a sacrifice
hey DJ play the sacrifice official song
we don't want to look that way please do
this alright DJ play the second song and
sacrificial all water sheep please
accept our humble offering
[Music]
whoa what is that
Sven it's a book it's called epic so
there is a way to communicate thank you
for your sacrifice please find a map to
the nether fortress thingy water sheep
oh my god
thank you what okay so what we're gonna
do spend is we're gonna go out this is
this is wilter sheep this is one good
one thing we have these magma blaze rods
and ender pearls we have a lot of ender
pearls for ones and so I think you do
this I'm not sure and then you do this
yes
all right let's bring a couple because I
think they break on the way when you're
coming with me
should I bring Garrigan smoking I feel
like I should bring Jurgen smart again I
think I think two pegs is well enough to
bring okay sorry class all down the
fortress okay so last time we threw the
ender pearl or the eye of ender it went
that direction so I think we should just
start going there so I want to throw it
as little as possible okay as long as
it's not as far as the freaking mansion
oh god it could actually be as far as
the mansion oh god I don't want to do
that at least then you know Ellie's man
because I think we're gonna have to go
far and I I can't do that to our walk
again I just can't
damn that the Church of of sheep looks
actually pretty good all right same hole
you guys hold down the fort
us gamers must rise it's just if we hit
water it becomes such a problem oh my
gosh what happened here
all right let's toss it how do I do it
again oh I did it I did it he went that
way
this way your again let's go did I pick
it up I didn't pick it up I gotta pick
it up each time I think it's like a low
chance of breaking or did I pick it up
oh gosh I'm gonna get I think there's
water this way it just hit me this is
the way to the jungle
so the fortress will be somewhere in
underneath the ground that's right here
again
where's it going this way oh god we
might have to go through the jungle
let's do another toss well this way oh
yeah I build the bridge here before Oh
God
so he doesn't tell you how far away so
it could just I mean I could have two
hours in front of me basically at least
it'll go quick over there again
oh here's another city oh there's more
people to kidnap here are they alive yes
okay we'll come back and kidnap Oh God
can it be underwater
alright it broke damn dang it I got it I
forgot to bring a boat as well I make a
boat for you and I okay you're too
shabby you can't go and both how I make
boat I forgot it's wet oh yeah at least
add a leash let's go here such an
awkward access as well to go that way
then if we build a portal we have to
make it like cuz I'm gonna do a portal
on the way back oh gosh that never ends
there's the jungle the young girls moon
good this is the worst place ever to
bring a freaking horse oh my gosh
alright I guess it's tossed time just to
make sure we're in the right direction
hopefully doesn't line in a tree or
something what excuse me what what okay
so we're getting close
we're getting close yet again spread
again get against my ghost or that
that's a little temper there okay let's
check out what's inside I got a coin
infinity and stuff oh these are rare I
know that now I've learned gamer hasn't
learned oh god I'm gonna die there was
nothing in there year again
false alarm let's keep going I on the
prize baby eye on the prize let's throw
that right there to throw it in here
yeah frigate why not what where do you
go oh there we are really close gamer
another ikea bird claws how are you
doing Oh
freaky landing
here so it's in the jungle again this
way don't break brick I'll have two left
okay here's nice and open come on what
it landed here you must be super close
you should probably start digging soon I
think this is it it landed on top of me
am I crazy or let's try from a distance
if it goes into the circle will net why
am i lagging uragan yeah yeah yeah look
at that
we literally found this spot let me try
that again
look at that it's here here we found it
Garrigan
we found it you stay there of course it
has to be in Warner right did I bring
sponges no because why would I am a
gamer which is not drowned so I just dig
like straight down how far deep can it
be
hey lava it's kind of strangely lit up
here probably lava before I'm getting
food oh my god it went in so I should be
able to find it quite easily then come
on gamers the Caesar game of rains don't
like the sound of lava don't like very
much God fully stack the diamond but
lava is very tough looking for the
fortress Jurgen is cold outside I think
I freaking pop our way it's my own
staircase
I found my own staircase guys maybe it's
just deeper you know I'm saying you know
I'm saying okay we're here monsters I
should be a good sign right because
there has to be spawn monsters in caves
oh yes oh god this is dangerous there
they are
found you gamers come up then I ain't
afraid
I'm fully stacked fully stacked fully
stacked guess who still got it so many
kill the babies those things are baby
don't think oh we had a little carrot
thank you okay we got to be careful hair
gamers don't think so gamers oh God
[Music]
get away get away
they keep spawning blow up then blow up
then blow up then or not ha ha whoa it's
because my render distance is so low oh
my god this place is a nightmare dude oh
my god
no get away
[Music]
take the door ranks
free running video game oh my gosh this
place has so many more oh my gosh don't
have to chestnut the chest
ah oh this phantom gosh I hate them what
what the Frick are you yeah
hedgehogs good let's give me the loot
that is crap loot I have Endor more like
don't care why does this seem like a
trap oh god okay cool
now I'm locked in boxers area another
chef sir okay I'll take I'll take are
these like hidden doors or just nothing
nothing Hedgehog kill okay so this is
where we came from is this a secret room
Oh
[Music]
don't do it creeper god he didn't have
to die this is intense
yeah they got villagers apparently you
can cure them I'll come back and cure
you buddy oh okay this is a place in the
beginning okay we found the library whoa
I know there's a treasure in here it's
like a hidden treasure somewhere there
it is yay books oh maybe they're good at
fishes look for power for what is this
sharpness three last protection
multi-shot efficiency power I could put
this on right
epic bow alright I'll take I'll take
maybe I'll come back later for all these
books but for now this gamers got to
find the main room and it ain't here I'm
sorry do you guys live here wait there's
two there's two bookshelf rooms oh there
is well I can go up here this is so cool
there's a chest
if only Sven would see this you'd be
amazed I can't wait to tell you it again
what is this crap you serious I never
get good stuff
did someone talk did someone talk don't
think so whoa what would
we're hidden in the ground they're like
fake blocks or something all right we're
getting close
FLIR English help see how you doing in
there buddy baby's got anything gosh
what I've never seen the whoa another
chest for him I mean I'll take it for
this be it another chest
I don't want good to spit I think this
is it oh my god how big is this place
oh my gosh dude oh all right
that's a new strategy oh my god this
place never ends I just steal torches on
all right we're going deeper boys
I found it this is a spawner cover it up
my last bit of torches hmm
there's already a couple in there so
what you do is that make a little noises
once this whole thing is covered the
portal to the nether will open to the
ender dragon oh my god dude you didn't
think I would make it this far did you
so we'll set up a portal somewhere here
freakish either someone is faffing or
there's some funky business going on
where is that fat thing coming from oh
my god oh you're too cute to kill I'm
sorry I'm sorry
yes slime yes come to Papa
snappy moppy dude 9 slimes Frick yeah
where I come from
okay let's get lit so will this take me
back home or will this take me because I
can't leave without your again oh this
connects to another portal I made ok
well that works out this is my North
portal strange I don't understand how
that works
Oh Oh see this is my jungle portal oh
gosh I gotta find uragan now yeah get
I'm back oh my god and I'm level 30
freak yet alright let's just build just
in case we need to come back here I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know look how high I
am you're good look at old I am guess
I'm not the little should be anymore
you're again look how tall I am here
again literally taller than the trees
gamer this is almost gonna be as
impressive as Tower of Ikea and put a
lantern up there at first now that's
just a waste there we go
oh ho I was a little nervous not gonna
lie hey your game where's your leash
[Music]
wait are you telling me Jurgen has been
staying there without a frickin leash
and you didn't run away what he could
have ran away in the jungle he would
have been impossible to find him oh my
gosh we're sorry dad okay we're gonna
head back now my portal is over here I
don't know why it ended up here so
confusing oh gosh I don't have a leash
I do have slime I could make it uh but
the precious slime uh fine this is how
much I love you
I hope this shows once and for all if
there was any doubt don't need it but I
need your again freak damn it now I'm
very confused compensating my house is
over there no wait compass was freaked
up see there's the portal like what gosh
I'm so tempted to kidnap these guys oh
my god it's so beautiful here again I
get teary-eyed every time I see it
the maple of love the maple of
friendship back and here we go gamers
we're but nevermind
no no sheep no she perfect
what up gamers were back and we found
thank you what their sheep we found the
portal play my favorite song DJ we're
fully kitted diamond we found the last
bit of the game everyone is here it's an
awesome time to be playing Minecraft
[Music]
thanks guys for watching another episode
of Minecraft smash like and subscribe if
you want more and enjoyed and if you
SuperDuper enjoyed why not support the
channel get some epic merchants support
arrogant support spin and all the tips
is that right for the worst DJ ever
alright there's cream pie signing up
believing I care power and good things
will come to you bye bye